revolutionize digital marketing by
streamlining content creation across
platforms through its engaging blogs
social media posts and persuasive
copywriting while also fostering
customer engagement via instant
responses on social media personalized
user experience and efficient automated
customer support it further AIDS in SEO
efforts by suggesting relevant keywords
enable Trend analysis for strategic
insights assist in content localization
for Global reach facilitates the
creation of interactive content like
quizzes and paults and even contributes
to a b testing variations all of which
collectively Empower marketers to
enhance efficiency engagement and
overall camp and success on that note
check Ai and machine learning bootcamp
by simply learn this will help you to
advance your career as an eiml
specialist with an expertise in chat GPT
the AIML bootcamp includes live classes
delivered by industry experts Hands-On
apps industrial relevant projects and
master classes by Celtic professors
skills are necessary for the Career
Success with this AIML bootcamp you will
learn generative AI prompt engineering
chat GPT explainable AI machine learning
algorithms supervised and unsupervised
learning model training and optimization
so why wait join now find the course
Link in the description box however if
you are looking to become digital
marketing expert then check simply lands
postgraduate program in digital
marketing and learn from top digital
marketers in the industry find the
course Link in the description box here
the success stories of our Learners in
their own words change is inevitable but
growth is optional
for me both came hand in hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learn present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aim for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with Purdue University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiling
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings I but also the courses
were economically charged the modules
were very informative and amazing I
still refer to those while in the final
stage of my course I told my Superior
about the certification program I was
doing and then it offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive this that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I'm pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete a Masters
program including artificial
intelligence cloud computing and devops
and many more growing requires moving
out of our comfort zones
keep learning so without any further ado
over to our tutors Jack GPD is truly a
fascinating technology changing how we
interact with language it's the result
of years of research and development by
open AI who have trained the model on a
massive amount of Text data to create a
machine that can easily understand and
generate human-like text imagine you are
a digital marketer looking to make a big
impact on your next campaign chair GPT
can help you do that chargeivity uses
natural language processing or NLP which
can assist you in creating compelling
human-like copy for your website social
media and email marketing it can even
generate product descriptions and AD
copy that is engaging and optimized for
search engines using chatgpt will save
time and increase your productivity
allowing you to focus on other important
aspects of your campaign and with its
ability to generate multiple text
variations you can test and Define your
messaging to find the perfect tone and
language that resonates with your target
audience get ready to revolutionize your
digital marketing game with the help of
this video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how change apt can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open AI launched chatgpt it has
been making waves in every feed be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
open AI the company behind the
development of CIA jpt and your options
are option A Elon Musk and Sam Altman
option b Jeff Bezos and satyana data
option C Mark Zuckerberg and Larry Page
option D segma and masayoshi Sun Drop
your answer in the comment section below
okay then let's get started there are
many uses of chat jpt in digital
marketing its main USB is smart human
sounding content writing we can command
it to write content related to marketing
first on our agenda is an ad copy there
are various ways to go about it but we
must understand that no matter how much
content sounds like humans it is still a
piece of content written by an AI so you
have to give detailed and precise
queries to get the best results let's
start by giving it a basic command like
write an ad copy
foreign
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learn digital marketing Master scores
[Music]
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it longer
[Music]
thank you
and hola it gave us a long version of
that same content now let's try to
convert it into email newsletters V
digital marketers often send emails to
promote our products and services so
let's give it a query as can you convert
it to email newsletters
as you can see it has generated an email
with a subject line and body that is
enticing and engaging to read we can
also utilize chat GPT to correct grammar
or change the tone of the content for
example let's enter new query what is
Facebook
[Music]
it has given us a general overview of
Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase it
more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital marketing
together
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
replaced it and it is more interesting
to read it as well GPT can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more Search
keywords for a digital marketing core
site
[Music]
and Bola it has completed a work we used
to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing
give us some keywords you can ask it to
reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords volume
[Music]
here we have some suggestions let's pick
a topic content writing and ask it to
write an article on content writing
[Music]
here we have an article for the blog
let's use chatgpt to SEO optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta description
[Music]
here we have meta title and meta
description for this article we can even
request it to give us an SEO optimized
URL link
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search results
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
optimized article with meta title and
meta description where the SEO optimized
URL chat GPT can also be used to train
your customer service chatbots but we
can discuss the process in some other
video chatgpt is well burst with its
content writing capabilities it can even
help you write product marketing
campaigns let's try it with this query
the queries write a product marketing
campaign for simple and digital
marketing courses
thank you
well chat Deputy has done it again this
campaign looks interesting and it will
be able to generate more leads for
simple lens courses chat jpd can also be
used to write scripts for YouTube videos
let's give it a query as write a script
for five minute YouTube video promoting
simply learn and its digital marketing
courses
foreign
[Music]
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if you
are a content creator and you don't know
how to approach other content creators
for a collaborative video then chatgpt
can help you with that it can help you
writing collaboration emails as well my
next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital marketing
[Music]
since my last query was related to
Simply learn chatgpt assured that I work
for simplion and I wrote a customer
collaboration email that looks
professional plus easy to read and
understand during our childhood we have
heard the fictional stories of robots
taking over various household courses
making the lives of humans easy peasy
but if you are not aware then these
fictional stories are turning into
reality though not in the form of
physical robots but yes in the form of
computer programs and apps with the help
of artificial intelligence and machine
learning Technologies
confused let me introduce to you to chat
GPT a pre-trained model that interacts
with user in a conversational way Chad
GPT is founded by open Ai and the model
is based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chargpt chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat gbd in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chargpt will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by open AI Option 1 chat jpt1
option 2 chat gbd2 option 3 chat GPT 3
and option for none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a are from Simply learned we
know that SEO rankings depends on
various factors like on-page
optimization of page optimization and
more while using chat gbt we will
understand how chat GPT helps in various
SEO ranking parameters and reduces the
manual work so without any further delay
let's begin so to begin with let's open
chat GPT
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SEO optimized blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog
so before that let's choose what kind of
blog we want to create I really love
traveling so let's try to create a
travel blog so for the travel blog we'll
find some good keywords
foreign
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results
so let's try to get something for Japan
so just make good keywords to create a
blog
going with Japan
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are a few places
like Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
foreign
keywords related to top 10 places in
Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for for search for for search
rankings
write me a Blog on
top 10
places
to visit
in Japan
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to uh
optimize the block with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat GPT
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like uh uh chat jpg provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to say every number of words
like if this Blog has two thousand or
five thousand words you can just ask
chat GPT to reduce it to 2000 or 1000
words also
so here you can see that
before when we search there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this blog
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more key words
to increase its reach
suggest
you
more development
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
foreign
title helps the user to click on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
add the best
suitable
title in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
visit in Japan top 10 places to visit in
Japan
but then
optimized
title
foreign
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to
add the title on the Block
optimize
blog
for the
keyword
top 10 places to visit and which
okay so it is showing the relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
ambiguity in the query that's why it's
not representing us the correct results
we are going to optimize our blog using
all these factors
visit in Japan
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
foreign
s H1 H2
in the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for getting your page rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me few
intern links
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these blog pages in your
website or if you have created any of
these blogs earlier do Interlink it
which of the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above
but it is also showing the significance
of interlinking
okay moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our blog
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 places to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this blog
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of kuyoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and see if we
are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image idea for Mount
so let's see we have seen in generic for
all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
block for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
mount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
then a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and all tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
good
title and
Alt
tag
for
mount
Z image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
scenic
Fuji
Lakes Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
shows
the mound
LG image for my blog
choose image
it should not I repeat
choose the perfect
illustration for
amount fusing
image for my
block
so you can see that it is not choosing
any image but it is again providing us a
suggestion what we can choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of an unsplash pixels
or Shadow stock to download the image so
we can really navigate to these websites
and download some of the required image
for our blog
so we we have uh completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
for your blog page
suggest me
suggest
video ideas
for
above
block
okay so we are getting few of the video
ideas
which of the
other idea is best match for my blog the
try to extract anyone from the above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
for
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide video optimization optimization
ideas
video optimizations
for
amount
using video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions what we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
Mount Fuji uh thumbnail uh image
suggestion and the video tag suggestion
right
suggest me
good
thumbnail idea
for
Mount Fuji
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
I repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
tags
all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
above block
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine size that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another users
so the search engines by by these search
engines understand that your content is
really good and it is worth of ranking
so definitely getting a good backlink
from a very good authority websites is
fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites
which are showing more of the trip
oriented or bookings related oriented
for travel or destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites and social media
platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so
let's check
how can we get
backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one
and get one of the black
a repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our blog
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is uh which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get one
is with the
create SEO
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description
for the key word
top 10
places to
visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got the recommendation the
previously and this one also both are
completely relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate this kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO optimized
URL for the
above block
see so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which sharing options
should I add
in my
blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four shading
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common WhatsApp Shares are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backing for their web and this is
again going in symbiotic way like if
they are asking for a battling for from
your blog you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
duplicate
content
above
log so duplicate content is a concept
where search engines you you must be
aware that social engines are really in
love with the unique content so having a
duplicate content may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so plagiarism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to charge
everybody is not able to identify the
duplicate content however it is
suggesting that some of the tools like
copyscape or siteliner to understand if
the content we are creating for our blog
is duplicate or not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create a unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is four not four pages four not
four pages are
really
not are not likely to get searched
because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
foreign
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the chat GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like a screaming frog or
Google search console where we get the
detailed report of the broken links or
404 pages that is the dead pages of our
website
so let's wrap up from the view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
paid advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your
a content and share it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things if you are
looking become digital marketing expert
then check simply lands post graduate
program in digital marketing and learn
from top digital marketers in the
industry find the course Link in the
description box
today in an era of mobile devices robots
and social media content creation is the
most effective inbound marketing
strategy
nearly 40 percent of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81 percent say
their company views content as a
business strategy
original and high quality content can
help your company stand out and attract
your customers and help your business
grow on that note welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we are here
with a fantastic video on chat GPT for
Content creation which will help you
create some compelling content on your
desired topics so let us understand what
is chat GPT here now content creation
can be of any type such as blogs
podcasts videos graphics and so on but
how do you create high quality content
with a few minutes do not be worried
when we have chat GPT now even though
there are numerous air riding tools for
Content creation chat GPT stands for
from the crowd due to its faster
response rate ease of use increased
productivity support for multiple
languages and other benefits now let's
try to understand what exactly chat
Jupiter is and how to create content
from it
now generally charge GPT is an open AI
trained and developed model that works
conversationally
chat GPT is capable of systematically
resolving all bugs while providing
detailed explanation for each step it
takes so in simple words charge GPT is a
tool that creates content for any query
chart GPT stands out among all the other
achievements of open AI
so let us now move ahead and understand
how does chat GPT work now chart GPT
uses deep learning techniques to
generate human-like text which is based
on a machine learning model derived from
the large language model class now it is
trained on a massive Text data sets from
the internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chart GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers shared their views on an
individual subject now there are a
variety of categories for writing a Blog
so let's pick one for chat GPD here
so as you can see we have navigated into
charge APD and let us now ask a simple
question about food blogging now lately
food blogs are the most popular blogs
that everyone wants to write about so
let's find out what chat GPT has to say
about it now you can give any question
to charge GPT and it will answer so I'm
just writing a question here saying how
to
start a foot
blogging carrier
so as you can see it is generating the
answer for us wait for it to end
well as you can see it is saying that
starting a foot block can be a fun and
rewarding way to share your love or food
with others so it is showing us some
steps to get started in food blogging
career it is saying choose Anisha choose
a name and domain choose a blogging
platform create your blog create high
quality content and so on so in this way
charging Beauty will automatically
generate the response for you based on
the questions that you are giving input
to it next we will see another question
on lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in charge GPT as
well and see what it will show the
answer so let's uh give the question as
how to
start
lifestyle
blogging in India
so it is giving the answer for us guys
so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interests so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
uh important points whereas in order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your Niche choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on chat GPT has been
helping in various Fields like customer
support virtual assistant education
content generation language translation
research and information retrieval
personal productivity entertainment and
more now talking about content creation
then chat GPT can prove a valuable tool
in idea generation writing enhancement
research and fact checking SEO
optimization and social media content
chat GPT can assist you with content SEO
or search engine optimization in
following ways number one is keyword
research chat GPT can help you to
identify the relevant keywords and key
phrases that are commonly used in your
industry or required for your topic by
discussing your content with chat gbd
you can uncover valuable keywords to
optimize your content for search engines
so let's find some keywords to create
content on shoes we will create a blog
on shoes so let's add query to chat GPT
so here we got few suggestions we can
pick any of them if needed you can check
these keywords in any keyword research
tool to check their search volumes if
you require so let's choose this keyword
let's write a blog using chat GPT in 500
words on this keyword
the next we have is content optimization
chat GPT can provide insights on how to
optimize content for better search
engine rankings it can suggest where to
include keywords naturally within your
content recommends heading structure and
advice on appropriate keyword density so
to the above created blog let's find the
optimization
so here we saw the number of
optimizations suggested by chat GPT for
our content the next we have is meta
tags and descriptions chat GPT can help
you to generate compelling meta tags and
descriptions that accurately represent
your content these elements are
important for search engines to
understand the topic of your content and
display relevant information in search
results so let's ask chat GPD to write a
creative meta descriptions meta title
and meta tags for this block
if needed we can rephrase these meta
descriptions and titles as per our
requirement by providing another query
the next trick to master SEO content
with chat gpts content length and
quality
Jag GPT can guide you on the ideal
length of your content based on the
search engine algorithms and user
preferences it can help you to ensure
that your content is of high quality
engaging and informative which can
positively infect on your SEO ranking so
let's understand what can be the ideal
length of this shoe blog
as we have already written a 500 Words
length of block let's change it to
another one suggested by chat GPT
interlinking and site structure chat GPT
can provide suggestions on how to
structure your content and incorporate
interlinks effectively interlinking
helps search engines to navigate your
website and understand the relationship
between different pages boosting your
overall SEO so let's get few of the link
recommendations for our blogs on shoes
the next one we have is user intent and
readability chat GPT can assist in
understanding user intent and optimizing
your content accordingly by discussing
potential user queries and preferences
you can create content that aligns with
what users are looking for enhancing its
relevance and readability so let's check
out if the readability of the given
block or block created by chat GPT is
good or not
you can also test some other content
with chat GPT to check whether its
readability is good or not while child
GPT can provide a valuable guidance it's
important to remember that SEO is a
complex field and requires a holistic
approach it's advisable to combine chat
GPT suggestions with best practices
industry knowledge and ongoing SEO
strategies to achieve optimal results
did you know Microsoft is planning to
invest 10 million dollars in charge gbt
developer even silicon Valley's biggest
conglomerates have begun to take note of
charge gbt versatility and practicality
people have started earning money
through chargeability and some even
predict the Revolutionary AI chatbot
will replace Google search but what
makes charge ability so resourceful what
charged is and how it works and at the
end we will discuss some of the ways
that chair GPT is being used the real
world the potential implications of this
technology from chat boards to language
translation chat Jeopardy has many
applications that make it easier for
businesses and individuals to interact
with technology so hello everyone I am
mank and welcome to Simply learn make
sure you are subscribed to our Channel
and hit that Bell icon to stay updated
with the latest technological Trends
before we move on to the demo part let's
discuss what chargibility is and proceed
further for the same so what is
chargibility charitability position
language model created by open AI it is
a form of generative pre-trained
transformed gbt model which was trained
on a data set of conversational problems
such as dialogue Snippets and chat logs
the model is capable of generating
human-like responses to text input so
now let's understand how charge gbt
actually works this model is pre-trained
on a large tax data set and then fine
tune on a smaller data set specific to
the everyday task when the model
receives input from a user it uses the
pattern it learned during fine tuning to
generate a response let's take another
example the model can generate an
appropriate response even if the input
is not a complete question or a sentence
after seeing what is charge gbt and how
it works now moving forward let's see
how we can use shared GPT in our
day-to-day life
so this is a Google search here we will
write
chat dot open AI
.com
it will take time
so this is the chat window UI
objectivity
so our first use case is chargpt can
explain complex subjects okay so first
we will ask like what
is neuroscience
it will take time
it's taking time to load because many of
the users are using
it started Neuroscience is the
scientific study of the nervous system
which includes the brain it will write
all about the Neuroscience you can ask
anything any subject okay like Heart to
Heart easy any or even you can stop
generating two if you want to
okay so this is how you can ask like any
question to the any complex question to
charge everything okay uh we'll ask one
more like what is
quantum
it's loading
I don't know why it's taking time
because of net issue or I don't know why
take time and it will come
that uses properties of quantum
mechanics to perform operations on data
like this okay
two states zero or one and all the
quantum Computing knowledge
okay
so this is how you can ask anything like
any com about any complex subject to the
charge ability okay
so with chat our Second Use case is we
can write code using chat GPT okay we
can write so here I will give give me
a machine
learning
program
called
application
okay press enter
okay so here it's starting here is a
simple Python program that uses scient
Library there's this and this
yes this is how you can take write a
code any code if you ask anything like
sorting like add two numbers
palindrome
anything you can anything you can ask
from chargibility it will give you a
code proper code
edit right please note that this is a
simple example of sort prediction is a
complex task and this example is not
enough to make a good prediction it
would need a lot more data feature
engineering and model tuning to make
accurate prediction Okay so
let me give another Java
implementations implementation
of the what bubble
algorithm okay
let me ask this
yeah it started like here is a Java
implementation of the bubble sort
algorithm
so
if you proper runnable algorithm
okay like bubble sort
of give you full
you can ask any type of code any type of
like apis anything
it will explain to this implementation
using nested Loop to compare adjacent
elements in the area and swipe them if
they are in the wrong order
okay
and then after the outer loop completes
the array will be sorted in ascending
order our third use case is we can debug
the code okay so for that
but I will I will take this one code
okay
I will take this code
and
here I will write debug the code and I
will paste it here
and what I will do I will instead of
temp
here
I will like I will write
okay I will add 2p okay so now
what it will do charge but it will do it
will develop see the error in the code
is in the this line
it should be temp
you can see here
it is stamp
so from charity you can debug the error
okay you can have the conversation with
to pull the charge body like if you have
any question you can directly write
what's wrong in the other question and
like this okay like you have an extra p
in this variable name which is causing a
compile error this is because temp is
the variable that you declared earlier
to store the value of current element
where a stamp is not a variable that has
been declared so here you can see
the stamp is declared here so that is
that the error is causing the code not
to run once you fix the issue okay like
sort the arrange or sending audio
okay so using chat GPT you can easily
debug your errors the code and it is
very helpful on your project building
okay so fourth use case is you can
create custom marketing plans or
strategy okay I'm repeating again you
can create custom marketing plans or
strategy like how so here I will write
how
could
remote
videos
on
social
media
president
it will give you proper plan how you can
promote your YouTube videos on your
social media
okay
I will chat with this okay I will ask
some question
views engagement everyone knows there
are few strategies you can use C per
second and more like more to come like
share your video on personal social
media accounts us include your Facebook
Twitter Instagram and other accounts
thing like that join the 11 communities
and groups through use social media ads
platform like Facebook and stuff
Instagram and Twitter
collaborate with influencer it is also
true create a hashtag for your videos
use YouTube video built-in sharing
features
it will give you all the marketing plans
it can create marketing plans any type
of plans
see remember your video should be
engaging information and should we
provide value to our audience
it is something like that now I will ask
one question to charge gbt
Okay so
I will ask what
if
make
only
travel videos
okay
what if I will make only okay
travel videos
so how
should
I
capture the
audience
you can ask any type of question okay
relevant to
this question or this answer you got
okay now let's see
it will give you everything if you are
making travel videos there are like few
strategies you can use to capture and
engage your audience
like this okay so the unique interesting
aspect of the destination you visit
people are often thrown to new and
unique experience like say share your
personal experience and insights it will
give you a proper plan
like how you can increase your audience
engage your audience okay
collaborate other travel bloggers that's
true engage with Audience by responding
to comments messages through
remember your video should be visually
appealing and provide valuable
information to your audience it is also
important to be authentic and true to
yourself like that okay so this is how
you can like using chat gbd how you can
create your marketing plans or your
something like that okay so our fifth
use case is we can generate articles and
blogs using shared GPT okay so let me
ask right and
article
Sheen
learning
because also machine learning kind of
machine learning on machine learning
in
500 Words
presented
it will write only exactly like 500
Words it will give you only 500 words
like machine learning is rapidly growing
field that is transforming the way we
live and work it is the branch of
artificial intelligence blah blah
basic idea of machine learning is that
computers can learn from data without
being explicitly programmed
like supervised learning is the most
common type of the machine learning just
through
yeah you can see here there are three
main types of machine learning
supervised learning and supervise and
reinforcement
it's true it will tell about it will
write a proper
article in only 500 word not more than
that
okay
machine learning has a potential
application Healthcare machine learning
patient data and more accurate diagnosis
like that
500 Words
it will give you exactly 500 Words
and conversion machine learning is
rapidly growing period that has the
portion into professionalize many
Industries it allows computers to learn
from the data without being explicitly
programmed
this is 500 Words of article
okay you can ask write article videos
descriptions blogs any kind of content
writing you can see
okay so let's do one more question and
the same so I will like give me
money
on
to write
okay skip for my YouTube
Channel
YouTube channel YouTube shorts
videos
video on Cyber
security
okay
so here is a short skip for funny
YouTube video on cyber security
like narrator
where every clip could be your last
exactly
so something like that
always use strong password like password
One Two Three or fourteen
tip number two never click on suspicious
link unless it's linked to be to repeat
the
see this is how you can create your
funny
how you can generate your content from
chargpt using chargity okay
thanks for watching stay safe out there
please note that that's description just
for fun exactly we know and not mean to
be taken seriously it's important to
take cyber security seriously and follow
best practices to protect your person
and professional data
okay
so this is how you can write
your make your content so easily like by
writing the title of the content so our
six use cases you can even Summarize the
book or article using child GPT like how
I will write here summarize
the book
delivers travel
s
no word written by Jonathan Swift and
this the book does the story of limel
deliver a ship surgeon who becomes
Shipwrecked it will light only and will
summarize all about delivered travel
yeah in part one this happened
Oliver washes up on the island of
lilliputia exactly
do this happen and part three this
happens
this is how you can summarize any book
any related to like educational no world
fiction any type of book or article and
blogs
okay whatever you want to summarize
it will run the book is being commented
on the Society of ship to one time
okay so this is how you can Summarize
the book fully master
our seventh use cases we can ask
interview question two using chargeable
so here I can ask how to answer
interviewer
what
is
your
weakness
okay
so when answering the question it is the
best to be honest but also to frame your
answer in a positive way yeah exactly
for example you could say something like
I have a tendency to be perfectionate
and sometimes struggle with delegating
task however I have been working on this
learning like this you can ask any
question any interview type question
okay related to HR or technical anything
you can ask
so let's see
how
to
answer
the
web viewer
like where do you see yourself
in next
five years
okay
so when answering this question it's
good idea to be aligned your answer with
the company's course and values yeah
exactly for example you could say
something like in five years I can see
myself going within the company and
taking more responsibility exactly
so this is how
you can ask any type of HR questions
you are facing off okay
so our next
use cases
our AIDS use cases we can develop apps
using charitivity
okay yes we can develop apps using
chargability like
I want
to write
an Android
app that
shows
me
please talk
prices
as a
list
um
let's see Yahoo
API
okay
how
can
I do
like this so it will write a proper
Android app code
for you
with a new Android project or it will
give you a proper idea how you can make
a you know app
all these steps
from starting to the last
choose a view holder to hold the
reference of the views for each item in
the list
okay
use asynchronous stars to fetch all the
step from starting to the end
this is a brief overview of the steps
and you will need to take a build
Android app
okay
okay so this is how you can like ask
anything to create
a
okay using any language plot Java python
any language
okay I repeat our ninth use case is we
can create our exercise plan diet plan
using chargpt okay
so I will write my width is 25 okay
let's take
25 kg
and I want to
lose
create
seven days
period seven days
plan
for
the advice
and type plan for it
okay
it will get see here is a day exercise
and the diet plan that can help you lose
day one exercise 30 minute risk walk or
joke right start your day with a healthy
breakfast of oatmeal berries like this
it will create exactly seven days
okay so this is our ninth use case we
can make any type of plant diet plan
food plan exercise plan or anything
like marketing strategy
anything you want
timetable
focusing something anything you can make
and according to you yourself you can
rearrange them okay it will be very easy
and it is very time saving
okay it will create seven days plan okay
six exercise training session like this
type
is you want to lose
avocado toast with post deck
so it's important to know that this is
just a plan Simple Plan
so our tense use cases last use case you
can ask any General Knowledge Questions
to chat
like
okay
who invented
first
provided by German goldsmen yeah
you can cross question to charge with
the answer
okay
this is the all the use case of Charity
like
it can or debug the code audit the code
like explain complex subject create
custom marketing plan or strategy diet
plan exercise plan you can generate your
content like article blogs you can
Summarize the book and the Articles or
interview question preparation or
developing apps coding
you can easily do with the charge GPD
okay I hope you understand how to use
chat GPT and what is charging okay and
the use cases of charge GPT and where
you can use in day-to-day life
artificial intelligence large language
models and AI chatbots have come a long
way and today we have many AI language
models which are helping us throughout
various domains few examples are
Microsoft's Bank Google's bar open AIS
chart GPT Megatron T5 and many more
today we will be discussing about the
caliber of chat GPD and AI which can
leverage you and help you to build a
perfect business so few of the reasons
that you need to consider are the
decision making capabilities of chat GPT
and AI customer services that you can
offer through chat GPT and AI chat GPT
potential to create a content and its
potential to leverage data analysis and
charge up it is an AI capabilities to
provide sales and marketing for you and
run automation for you we will discuss
each one of these in detail so the first
one is decision making capabilities of
chat GPT in terms of raw processing
speed chat GPT can analyze and generate
text at a rapid base capable of
processing and generating responses much
faster than a human can type or think it
can quickly access and retrieve
information from its pre-trained
knowledge providing intermediate answers
to suggestions therefore chat GPT excels
in processing and generating text at
higher speeds however it cannot be
directly compared to humans in terms of
decision making abilities however it is
proof that it is 90 accurate in addition
making whereas humans tend to be
accurate at a rate of 80 to 85 percent
charge GPT is anyways stronger in terms
of decision making at this case followed
by that moving ahead to the next reason
that is the customer service that charge
gbd and AI can help you with if you
compare a human the customer support
representative reads the customer care
compared to human the customer support
representative has to read the
customer's query analyze the problem and
formulate a response this process may
take a few minutes or more depending on
the complexity of the issue and
representatives typing speed right but
when you compare it with chart GPD the
AI powered chatbot like chat gbt quickly
scans and comprehends the customers
query it generates a response within
milliseconds providing intermediate
assistance as well so chat gbt's
proficient at providing customer
services at a much faster rate and it
can also eliminate you the cost of
hiring training and maintaining an
entire Army of customer services moving
ahead we have content creation if you
are a startup company or a company which
needs concentration for your product
then obviously you might end up hiring
Freelancers or a team of content
creators right but compared to humans
shared GPT is proficient at generating
content and can produce coherent and
contextually relevant text so you can
even save money by using the most
powerful and fully operational AI model
to create more versatile and highly
qualified content for you to avoid
hiring Freelancers and employees
the next reason is using AI models for
business data analysis AI can assist you
in data analysis by leveraging its
computational power and advanced
algorithms to possess and extract
valuable insights from large and complex
data sets AI algorithms can automate
data cleaning pattern recognition and
anomaly detection tasks enabling faster
and more accurate results AI models can
also perform Predictive Analytics
identifying Trends and making forecasts
based on historical data additionally AI
can facilitate data visualization
presenting information in intuitive and
interactive formats for better
understanding by automating repetitive
tasks and augmenting human capabilities
AI enhances the proficiency efficiency
accuracy and scalability of data
analysis procedures you can rely on AI
language model to extract transform and
load data and analyze your business data
and generate reports draw projections
and make data driven decisions to help
grow your company and this also Awards
you to hire and maintain a huge Army of
data analysts which may produce some or
the other errors in real time right and
next reason is sales and marketing chat
GPD can leverage sales and marketing
efforts in the following ways customer
engagement chargpt can engage with
potential customers in real time
answering their queries providing
product information and guiding them
through sales process it enhances
customer experience by delivering prompt
and personalized responses next is later
generation chargity can act as a virtual
assistant collecting and qualifying
leads by interacting through website
visitors it can gather relevant
information access customer needs and
provide initial assistance generating
valuable leads for the sales team 24 7
support share gpt's ability to operate
Around the Clock allows for continuous
customer support it can address
inquiries or for product recommendations
and resolve issues even outside regular
business hours improving customer
satisfaction and retention now instead
of hiring a team and manually marketing
your product on social media platforms
and spending thousands of dollars to run
paid marketing you can use AI models to
crack the algorithms and Market the
product to your target audience with
that let's proceed to the next reason
that is automating your tasks chat GPT
can automate business procedures in the
following ways the first one being
customer service charge APD can handle
customer inquiries Provide support and
resolve common issues through automated
chat interactions it reduces need for
human intervention saves time and
enables 24 7 customer support lead
qualifications chat gbt can engage with
potential customers ask qualifying
questions and and gather information to
assess their suitability as leads it
automates the initial stages of lead
qualification enabling sales team to
focus on most promising prospects only
next is data entry and processing chat
GPT can automate data entry tasks by
extracting relevant information from
various sources such as forms emails or
documents it reduces manual effort
improving accuracy and speeds up the
data processing appointment scheduling
charge GPD can integrate with scheduling
systems allowing customers to book
appointments or schedule meetings
automatically
finally workflow automation charge GPD
can integrate with business systems and
automated workflows it can initiate
actions send notifications or trigger
processes based on predefined rules
streamlining operations and improving
efficiency by automating various tasks
and processes chat Equity enhances
productivity reduces operational costs
and frees up human resources for
focusing on higher value activities with
their business so these were the few
important ways and reasons why charge
GPT and AI can help you make your
business if you are looking to become
digital marketing expert then check
simply lands postgraduate program in
digital marketing and learn from top
digital marketers in the industry find
the course Link in the description box
if you are looking for ways to generate
passive income without putting in too
much effort thanks to the advancement in
artificial intelligence and chat boards
it's now possible to earn money using
these Technologies in this video we'll
explore some of the effective ways to
generate passive income with Charity
charity is known for being the world's
smartest generative Ai and is changing
the game when it comes to making money
online with this revolutionary free tool
you can earn with little skill and no
Capital required there is an exciting
New Era of artificial intelligence and
now is the perfect time to get involved
and take advantage of this opportunity
people are using chat Jeopardy for
YouTube blogging freelancing and for
many other ways to make money so let's
dive in and discover how to make money
using shared deputy and generate various
passive incomes there are variety of
ways that you can make money using chat
Jeopardy we'll discuss few of them in
this video and we'll start with first
we'll see the list of all the ideas from
which you can make money the first is
get business ideas from chat Jeopardy
second is freelancing third is build a
software fourth is boost your affiliate
marketing with chat Jeopardy's email
expertise with this leverage Edge
ability for blogging success the next is
unlock the potential of charge Deputy
for affiliate marketing and then we have
utilize chat jbd for ebook writing and
self-publishing this is the main thing
what people are doing to make money
using charitability and then we have
utilized chat everybody to enhance your
YouTube channel and then we have writing
lyrics for music so starting them one by
one we'll start with get business ideas
from church Liberty by getting to know
your interest talent and obstacles chat
Jeopardy can generate tailored business
Concepts that align with your
expectations let's Dive Right In and ask
chat Jeopardy for some business ideas
for a computer science engineer who has
experience in digital marketing and
sales are chat repeating and ask him
that I am a
computer science graduate the computer
science engineer
with experience in sales and marketing
and what side Hustle
should I start
generate
around thousand dollars generate
thousand dollars
income that would be per day
and that would be with minimum
investment I want
and this is
minimum investment
and I can also tell him how many hours I
can dedicate so I can dedicate it
to 10 hours
to this side as well
press enter
so you could see that chat Jeopardy
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expense and sales and
marketing there's several side results
two generate thousand dollars income per
day
and he has stated the first one is
e-commerce then affiliate marketing
digital products you can create and sell
digital products such as ebooks okay
freelancing social media management and
YouTube channel you can start your
YouTube channel
so these are the ideas that you can get
from chat jbt and but these ideas
tailored to user skills and interests
that I have put in now it's time to take
these ideas and discuss them further
with chat Jeopardy to conceptualize a
plan so consider important factors like
alternatively you can begin by stating
generate a new business idea poor
digital products you can write that and
he will guide you how you can start it
or you could just write
can you elaborate
the business
idea
of
digital
products
I am on
to start the site
with this
and then you press enter
and you can see that it has started
the process for the business idea
certainly starting a side as well
centered around digital products can be
located in full screen Venture identify
your expertise
it manure areas of knowledge skills and
passion and then he has stated two Zone
product format create valuable content
set up an online platform Market your
products build an audience optimize for
conversions provide excellent customer
support so these are the parts he has
stated and moreover you can elaborate
those parts also you can just ask chat
Deputy so how can I identify my
expertise and he will guide you with
that so you can go deep down and explore
any business idea so this was the first
method through which you can generate
income from chair GPD and moving on the
next would be freelancing so take your
freelancing game to the next level with
chair Jeopardy this date of the art AI
tool is enabling professionals to earn
extra income and produce top quality
content that pose clients companies are
even offering incentives for those who
utilize this technology to create
polished well researched work so here
are some freelance services that you can
offer using chat GPT
starting with you can write blog or
website content using chatgpt for others
you can translate any language with jpt
you can craft compelling headlines and
calls to action with chat GPT and
moreover you can do create social media
content for posts or marketing for other
people or any advertising agency you can
write captivating short stories using
chat deputy and you can conduct hashtag
research using chatributing that is you
can find what is trending and offer your
services to other people and gain money
so these are the ways in which you could
freelance and have some money in your
pockets so you could just write a
command that would be write a blog post
and
you could write on any topic that would
be write a blow postcode
U.S economy
so you could use this AI tool as your
means like what the what your client
required you can use for that and write
the perfect without plagiarism content
that would be blog post and you can
translate any language with chai chpt
you can write
competitive headlines and calls and you
can also write social media content that
would be you can use SEO research for
that and you can write short stories
also see that he has given you the blog
post on the topic U.S economy the
navigating uh the title is navigating
the current state of the U.S economic
Trends and insights and you can see that
it has given you six points and if you
want more you can just ask him to
elaborate
elaborate this
and I've found this blog post
in 800 words
so the thing you just have to do is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
too in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat GPD
so now it will write the blog post that
would be in 800 words
so
that's good and moving on
what we'll do let's check out one of our
Learners what he has to say about our
courses you need to keep updating your
skills on a regular basis no matter what
level you're at I recently completed the
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
in partnership with Purdue University
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning now
coming back so the third passive income
you could make using chat to pts
building a software imagine this
scenario you have an issue with your
online business
and you realize that many other people
are facing the same problem well here's
where chair deputy comes to the rescue
you can utilize chair Jeopardy to create
software using report provided by the AI
and then you can sell these software
tools to make money it's as simple as
that by leveraging chat Jeopardy's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a ready Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also impose others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you are a problem solver and have a NAC
of four coding why not use charge Deputy
to create software tools that can make a
real happy start by identifying common
pain points that also you can ask from
chat Jeopardy you can just ask the chat
jpt I want to create a software to help
others during or in online processes in
online e-commerce so he'll give you
suggestions and then you can proceed
with those suggestions and create a
software and then you can sell it or you
can use for your own use
so now embrace the power chat jpt tap
into its coding expertise and unlock the
potential to create and sell software
tools so your journey to financial
success starts right here and moving on
we'll move to the next income source
that we can gain from chat jbd so you
can boost your affiliate marketing with
chat Jeopardy's email expertise so do
you know that chat Deputy processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatbot can drop
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services charitivity has
caught you power that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat GPT and ask
him that
email marketer
and need to
sell my CRM software
so right
an email
only
so I can attract
customer
and make them bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of
child supporting let's discuss how you
can Kickstart our email affiliate
marketing campaign the first step is to
choose an affiliate program that aligns
with your Niche whether it's Amazon's
Spotify Shopify convertkit or any other
program make sure it suits your target
audience next it's time to build an
email list of potential customers who
are generally interested in your
promoted products or Services you can
use lead magnets or employ other
effective methods to encourage email
signups you could see that he has
written the email that is I hope this
email finds you well as an email
marketed person okay this is for me and
you could start from here at your
company we have developed a powerful CRM
solution tailored specifically for email
marketers like yourself our software
combines Advanced features user friendly
okay here is written for uh email
marketers only as targeted audience that
is email marketer no issue you can ask
him to change that and like you can
craft compelling emails with chair
Jeopardy and this is where chat triple
truly shines with its assistance you can
create highly engaging emails that not
only inform users about the benefits of
the products but also Inspire them to
click on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chat about by
your side imagine having a chatbot by
your side helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compelling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click-through rates
so this is how chat Jeopardy can help
you in email marketing now the next
method is leverage charge Deputy for
blogging success in the realm of
blogging chair Jeopardy offers an array
of advantages that can elevate your
content creation Journey so the first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome brightness block
chat GPT assist bloggers by generating
ideas crafting outlines anyone providing
complete routes for blog posts say
goodbye to our spend on Research with
charge APD you can access relevant
information statistics and facts and
mere seconds elevate your blogging game
and Unleash Your Potential with this
invaluable source
and then you can add it and proofread
using charge update if you have written
any content and get any content written
you could just write what we have
already written that was write a blog
post on U.S economic that we have seen
in freelancing uh side Hustle but here
you can write and not only write but
also if you have added some points with
your research you can proofread and edit
by using charge APD that is for bloggery
proves to be a valuable asset by
offering assistance in editing
proofreading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat Jeopardy Define your writing and
ensure a blog posts shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for your blogging journey is keyword
research and SEO optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chargipti becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structure in your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat GPS SEO expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be gaming related
SEO keywords
for and the topic could be online
shopping
and press enter so here are some related
SEO keywords for online shopping you
could see all these you would mention
these on your backlinks if you have
website or you could add into your blog
posts hashtags which can gain you rank
when searched so moving back the next
was audience engagement so engaging your
audience is key to building a thriving
blow charity can assist you in
connecting with the readers on a deeper
level it towards conversation starters
answer common questions and addresses
concerns from your Audience by
leveraging Charity's capabilities you
can post on meaningful interactions
cultivated lower following and force
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of charge Deputy
bloggers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate their target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of charge deputy and embark on
an exciting blog Journey it will leave a
lasting impact so moving on we'll now
see another side herself that is unlock
the potential of chat Jeopardy for
affiliate marketing and you could do
easily affiliate marketing if you have
this vlogging thing
so affiliate marketing opens up a world
of earning possibilities and chat
Jeopardy can be your trusted Ally on
this rewarding Journey users of charge
Deputy can leverage its capabilities to
generate income through affiliate
marketing this powerful tool provides a
seamless Avenue for promoting Goods
services and Brands all while learning a
commission based on resulting sales
embarking on an affiliate marketing
Venture requires thoughtful planning as
a blogger or content creator you must
carefully select the medium through
which you will build your audience
whether it's through captivating
articles engaging audio content or
compelling videos you have the freedom
to choose the format that aligns with
your strengths and resonates with your
target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chair Deputy steps into support
your affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with by collaborating
with chair Jeopardy you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with with your audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy chargibility becomes an
invaluable resource it helps you to
draft engaging articles record
compelling audio content or script
captivating videos that highlight the
benefits and value of the products or
services that you are promoting so
remember affiliate marketing is a
process that requires dedication and
perseverance through consistent effort
and support of charge GPT you can unlock
the potential of earning substantial
income by promoting products and
services that resonate with your
audience and this was for the affiliate
marketing and the next big thing is
utilize chair Jeopardy for ebook writing
and self-publishing so are you a
passionate writer seeking fresh and
innovative ideas look no further charge
update revolutionizes your writing
experience in a recent report that
revealed that AI written ebooks have
experienced a remarkable search on
Amazon so you could just won't charge a
pretty and ask him
I want to write a self
help book
add to
Black version free
okay I think yeah no spelling is correct
and each should have
resonating
chapters there's no needing
chapters
so
provide me
with a list of chapters
as you can see that
it will Define you and you can also ask
the title for the book and it will give
you the perfect title and you can see
the chapters that is introducing setting
a stage for personal growth discovering
your authentic self cultivating a
positive mindset and after that you can
ask chat Deputy to elaborate these
topics that would be in some words in
some pages and you can use the same
content to write a book and you can also
ask the title from the chat Jeopardy
as you create a companion the
possibilities are boundless you don't
need to possess the skills of literary
genius to make an impact in the e-book
Market Kindle Direct publishing offers
seamless platform to Showcase your book
and make it easily accessible to
enthusiastic readers while leveraging
charge Deputy to assist in writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income
using chair GPD moving on we have next
passive income that is utilized chargpt
to enhance your YouTube channel
so chargeability is an invaluable tool
that can assist you in generating
captivating video ideas you can ask him
the video ideas also and this is the
creative block charge if you can even
cool the extra mile by creating a script
for YouTube videos
so let's tap into the creative pros and
we'll ask share jpt I want to create a
YouTube video
on topic
uh GDP
that is close domestic product and
I need your help
writing the script for that
so you could see that chair jpd has
started its work so it's showing welcome
back to our channel in today's video
we'll be diving into the fascinating
world of Tube8 GDP what exactly is GDP
and why is it such an important measure
of a country's economy so you can see
that it has created the script for your
YouTube video and it is also telling you
the scenes
so this is how you could leverage your
Japanese capabilities and that can give
you YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with chair Deputy today and witness your
channel Thrive so moving on the next we
have is writing lyrics for music so when
it comes to music the words we use in
songs are super important they have the
power to make us feel all kinds of
emotions and connect with people and now
there's a cool tool called chargeability
that can help you write awesome song
lyrics with chat you but you can take
your ideas and turn them into beautiful
words that touch people's heart it's
like having a virtual writing buddy that
help you come up with catchy lines and
cool Rhymes you can play around with
different ways to express yourself and
make your lyrics stand out so you can
chat GPT to write lyrics for you here
they wrap up chat GPT for digital
marketing tutorial
questions
share the video with your friends and do
not forget to like share and subscribe
to Simply learn to never miss any
updates from us thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign